[Music]
so i ran across
a article this week um
i think that my good friend preston sent
it to me
and it is remarkable not surprising at
all and i wanted to pass it along to you
we'll link to it in the show notes
it's an article from the atlantic
written by laura acknan
jamil zaki and elizabeth dunn i'm
confident that i just misspelled those
names
they are researchers at various
universities um
stanford simon fraser um others listen
all right here's the deal i'm gonna
start giving kelly
five dollars every time i say the word
listing because i just said it again
five bucks
i'm all for that perspective immediately
just come in over the thing
and let us all know perfect all right
not you
then just kidding i'll pay you give me
five dollars too
everybody in the booth five dollars for
you five dollars for you everybody
thanks oprah here's the
all right the name of the article is the
pandemic did not affect mental health
and the way you think
so like me i did it every mental health
professional i knew when the pandemic
set off
we all just looked at the
alleged death toll the fear-mongering
the true
and real fear the lockdown the isolation
the economic disaster the coming
economic disaster
the phrase the looming or the coming
fill in the blank
right whatever it was
and early on we saw devastating
anxiety numbers depression numbers
financial numbers
it was distress was just
climbing through the roof these
researchers say it climbed
dramatically right all over the world
and i'm going to read here but as spring
turned to summer something remarkable
happened
average levels of depression this is in
2020
and distress began to fall some data
sets even suggested that overall
psychological distress
returned to pre-pandemic levels by early
summer 2020
looking at the world as a whole we saw
no trace
of a decline in life satisfaction people
in 2020 rated their lives at a 5.75 on
average
identical to the average in previous
years so what does this mean
it's a story as old as time
and it's it's based in neuroscience
which is our brains have a vested
interest
in looking for the worst case scenario
and then trying to reverse engineer that
so that we don't die
our brains have a vested interest in
saying yeah but this might happen
and so we need to be careful about the
might the could be the maybes
and that is why we can't stop scrolling
that's why we can't stop watching news
headlines
that have disaster or looming or crisis
in the titles
that's why we can't stop watching the
stock market tick up and down and down
and up and up and down and down and up
and up and down
the the last time i saw the market a few
weeks ago
it was uh it's up some insane number
but it talked about oh it's down a
hundred points because of
it was a hundred points down that day
after being ten
thousand points up over the last few
years i mean it's just madness right
but our brains are so hardwired to look
for the next
hole in the ground the next thing that
might jump out behind a tree and eat us
but the tale as old as time is we are
incredibly
resilient we can overcome
adapt to solve for so many things
and as the authors write the pandemic
has been a test of the global
psychological immune system
which appears more robust than we ever
could have guessed
when familiar sources of enjoyment
evaporated in the spring of 2020 people
got creative
they participated in drive-by birthday
parties mutually assisted groups virtual
cocktail evenings with old friends
and nightly cheers for healthcare
workers some people got really good at
baking
many found a way to re-weave their
social tapestry
indeed across multiple large data sets
levels of loneliness
showed only a modest increase with 13.8
percent of adults in the us
compared with 11 in spring 2018.
people are incredible now here's the
thing
there was deep disastrous real pain
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of people have died of covet
alone in the united states
conspiracy theories aside lots and lots
and lots of people have suffered loss
in death plus car wrecks plus lost
jobs plus terrifying financial
conditions
all of it but hear what the author is
going to write
the astonishing resilience that most
people have exhibited in the face of the
sudden changes brought on by the
pandemic
hold its own lessons we learned that
people
can handle temporary changes to their
lifestyle such as working from home
giving up travel or even going into
isolation
better than some policy makers seem to
have seemed
to assume and here's why this is super
super important
we've got big time challenges on the
horizon
big time challenges whether they be
financial whether they be ecological
whether they be
political whether they be psychological
whether they be whatever
here's what the authors write human
beings are not
passive victims of change but active
stewards of our own well-being
this knowledge should empower us to make
the disruptive changes our society
societies may require even as we support
the individuals and communities that
have been hit
the hardest what does that mean
it means that we as a society as a group
as
individuals are hardwired to be
terrified of change
terrified of it so scared
and yet after what has been one of the
most
difficult and challenging crisis i don't
think it's over by a long shot
most difficult crisis many of us have
faced in our lifetimes collectively
our brains are solving for it our
relationships are solving for it we are
figuring out other ways we are getting
creative we are getting frustrated we
are
charting new paths we are slowly
recalibrating relationships we are
getting rid of stuff that we've been
carrying around
us for a long time we're deciding we are
gonna
make changes in our lives
and our bodies are saying cool we're
safe now
and so if you've got hard changes to
make
whether like today's calls whether it's
lorraine saying i
want to stop hurting people i want to
stop being so exhausted all the time
i want to stop being judge and jury or
whether it's like chris who
who wants to stop judging people who
have less than him
or wants to stop feeling guilty about
being successful
in his new job as new enterprise or it's
you you want to stop an addiction
you want to get control of your health
be good stewards of your mental health
learn how to have relationships and get
connected learn how to change your
thoughts
learn how to start acting differently
you can you can
this pandemic has been disastrous for
many of us
millions and millions worldwide but it's
also shown us a glimpse of light through
the cracks
we are strong and we are resilient
especially when we figure things out
together
so we'll link to that in the show notes
if you want to read it it's a really
remarkable read and again
just a little bit of light at the end of
the tunnel for some of us
you